[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by the brilliant
sarah adina smith director writer of
amazon original movie birds of paradise
it is out now how you doing today sarah
i'm doing great and i'm really excited
to talk to you
i'm really excited to talk to you um
it's cool you're in this like amazing hd
quality right now i feel like i'm
talking to like someone from a different
dimension it's just you should see what
i'm looking at because like when i was i
was told we were doing museums i just
was like oh it's just like with my
laptop but there's this whole like
amazing control room here happening it's
it's very this is amazing like i feel
like i'm like this is where you go and
you die like you're the person greeting
me like i see the light on you what do
you want to know i'm i'm i'm
yeah i'm the person at the gate guarding
the gates to wherever you're going i
will tell you
whatever i love it
okay so i'll tell you what i want to
know what i want to know is that you
brilliantly adapted a novel and having
that you adapt as a writer how do you
decide for that novel you know what to
keep in what to cut what is your process
on that
well luckily with this project i was
given carte blanche by the author to
just kind of take it and run with it
which is like that's that's the best um
as as a writer so i just kind of um
i i thought the book had a really um
enticing tone and i loved the idea of
this competitive world of ballet and
these characters and i kind of just ran
with it and wanted to explore the themes
that were most interesting to me um
which was really about like where
ambition and libido collide um and a lot
of questions about um
the fluidity of our identities as we're
starting to find out who we are
um
and then also themes about um grief and
pain and loss and about whether
redemption is possible even when you
perhaps have done something unredeemable
okay so that's interesting you talk
about the themes and i wonder when
you're you're consciously thinking about
the themes when you're writing
but
you're also trying to squeeze in
character arcs with
is it more challenging though being a
two-hander instead of just following one
protagonist here you're the first person
who's asked me that today and in it
absolutely is it's really hard to write
a movie that has two true protagonists
and i i kind of tried to do it with the
bait and switch so with this movie i was
giving i was kind of luring the audience
in with um a
storyline that you kind of recognize and
is a bit more expected of like here's
the outsider the sort of sort of more
clumsy dorky girl from virginia coming
into that competitive world of ballet
with the mean girl and you kind of like
get it and you think you get it
and then hopefully the movie surprises
you you know and we do sort of a
protagonist switcheroo on you
yeah and speaking of that protagonist
with giroux i also wonder is it
challenging because there's not in this
film a clear-cut
antagonist per se so when you're kind of
trying to find ways to create conflict
are you
yeah okay with doing it between your
protagonists instead of worrying about
having maybe just some straight-up
villain or you know i really love your
questions and i love that you asked that
because i really was trying not to make
um
i like
for this particular first of all i'm a
genre filmmaker i love genre i love when
things go arch you know but for this
movie i was trying to um you know play
to the genre of dance movies a little
bit but still have a really human core
and i like to approach things as a
writer and director of my characters
that like there it there is no evil
character necessarily you know you have
to kind of love each of your characters
and understand um
where even those um bad choices might
come from um rather than kind of judging
them as as villains
no i like that it's it and it's more
gray look to it and
it's interesting you you're you have
amazing two lead actresses here and you
get amazing performances out of them but
they're handling very heavy moments very
dark scenes
how conscious your view of making sure
you know they're comfortable as a
director how much responsibility is that
as a director for that for me that's my
the most sacred part of my job and i
consider it my um
my most important job as a director is
making sure um the actors know they can
trust me completely
and that i'm gonna create as um
the kind of space and the working
environment on set for them to do their
best work and to know that they can make
mistakes and that i want them to feel
like they can fail sometimes it's really
important to be able to fail in order so
that we can both discover something new
together um
so uh that is really paramount and and
particularly in roles like this where
not only are they being stretched
emotionally and spiritually and
intellectually but they're in rigorous
physical training so um that adds a
whole
additional layer you know in addition to
shooting all day they're still having to
work their bodies and and um it
i i think that um you know ballet is
probably one of the very most athletic
things humans can do
and diana and christine you know they
would be the first to say there's no way
to just become a ballerina overnight
they would have had to start training
when they were you know tiny children
um so
it's not like we were trying we're
we're not trying to fool the audience
into thinking that um all the ballet
dancing was done by them we used dance
doubles but they i am so proud of how
much um actually in the movie is the two
of them and how much they did on their
own and and not only that but by going
through all that rigorous physical
training i think it added a um real
um depth uh and complexity to their
characters because they they had um
experienced what it was like to have
that kind of discipline yeah no doubt
and it's you know i give props to
director for that to let their actors
show their best stuff and for me for
both those actors it was showing me that
range they have and you let them kind of
do their thing it comes off amazing you
know and i i think going back to the
adaptation i i wrote the adaptation for
them in mind specifically which i think
also
really helped because
i could um really tailor the characters
christine and diana
so talented and so different as people
and as actors and so it was such a treat
for me as a writer and a director to
think about crafting characters for each
of them that would play to their
strengths but then also push them and
challenge them to find new levels of
their craft um right and and
for a lot of ways you know this was an
exercise for me and like can i take two
up-and-coming exciting
new
um
you know new actors and break new movie
stars and i wanted to create a vehicle
for them that would show the world like
these two can carry movies that they're
yeah they're that good yeah and here's
the crazy thing is that you've also
created a vehicle for yourself because
this is exciting for you that this is
going to really put you more on the map
you this isn't your first rodeo but this
one i feel like will push you up those
director power rankings wherever those
power rankings are uh but everyone check
this film out it is out now on amazon
prime video it is birds of paradise you
are not going to regret watching us this
is awesome i'm so honored to be joined
by you today sarah and i hope to talk to
you in the future one day i love talking
to you thank you
thank you have a good one